thanks a lot to the organizers for
inviting me and thank you all for coming
so this this work is joint work with a
lot of people who all of us were at
Michigan when the work was done but now
I am the only fixed point jake has Jake
has moved to Georgia Tech chansu PhD
student whom Jake and I co-advised he's
moving to Google Pittsburgh Z fan was an
undergraduate when he did this work and
has moved to Yale pursuing his PhD and
audre is now a postdoc at Boston so so
what is this talk about so the talk is
actually about this pipeline so in a lot
of machine learning and statistics
applications what what people do is they
start with the data they you inject some
control amounts of randomness to get
some perturbed data and then you run
some optimization algorithm to finally
get your prediction function for a
regression problem or a classification
problem or a structured prediction
problem and we wanted to the question we
really wanted to answer which I don't
think we're fully answered but we've
made some progress is how do we show in
some principled way that this randomness
is acting as a regularizer so that that
was that kind of the over are the the
framework is can we understand adding
edition of structured randomness as as a
regularization
oh yeah this is just very very big
picture I'll zoom in yes I'd also say
why just why somebody doing real-time
decision making might be interested in
this so so I'll come back come down to
the two more details but this is just to
sort of set up the higher level
intuition so so some of you might know
about this technique called
bootstrapping it's very very widely used
in statistics also in machine learning
and maybe the most well-known
incarnation of this is random forests
right so the idea behind random forests
is you train you you have some data you
sub sample the data you do this many
many times in parallel and on each sub
sample you train a decision tree and
then in the end you you maybe average
these decision trees together to get a
forest right and random forests are one
of the best sort of off off-the-shelf
predictors so this idea is used a lot
and here the the controlled amount of
randomness is in generating these
bootstrap samples so you we use
randomness to select sub samples from
the samples we have and this this seems
to work very well in supervised learning
another another procedure of this sort
is the drop out used very widely in
training neural networks and and they're
it's sort of related to this idea of a
blank out noise which is if you have if
you have most of most of the time we
represent our data using some features
right so let's say you're doing credit
card scoring and you might have features
like how much of the what's the annual
income what's the zip code what's the
amount of current loan the person has so
you have all these features and you
might try to add some structured noise
to the features before feeding the raw
data to your machine learning algorithm
and one of the noise they use is for any
feature you you keep it with probability
P otherwise you zero it out so it will
it reduces sort of sparse matrices that
in expectation are equal to the initial
feature matrix that you
so so so these are just examples to tell
you that this happens all across the
board this type of this type of pipeline
which is central to what we study is all
over the place and so not it's not just
us but many machine learning researchers
have have tried to understand what's
what's going on in these types of
algorithms and as I said before one of
the emerging viewpoints is that well
really you can interpret at addition of
this randomness as regulation now there
was a question about what what is
regularization for those of you who
don't necessarily have machine learning
as their primary research area so
regularization in general it's a it's a
ill-defined term but but it usually
means something you do to control
overfitting in your model right so what
so what is overfitting overfitting is if
you use a very complex model and you
have limited amounts of data then it
might just memorize right and it will
not work well out-of-sample so to work
very well on the data you feed it but
it's not going to generalize very well
to out-of-sample data and if that
happens people say oh my model has over
fit and then you have to do something
what you do is is recognization right so
that's that's kind of a vague definition
so what we want to say is somehow that
this perturbation is acting as a
regularizer it's preventing preventing
overfitting and there is a nice book now
that includes contributions from lots of
researchers there were a series of nips
workshops during the years 2012 to 2014
and this book sort of evolved out of the
the contributions presented there so if
you're interested in this general area I
recommend this book titled perturbations
optimization and statistics okay so lots
of high level intuition let me get down
to some concrete examples so here's
here's actually maybe the most basic
result in this area and like a lot of
basic results this has been rediscovered
in different communities and it goes by
this name of the Gumbel lemma and I
actually until a couple of years ago
when I started research in this area I
didn't know about this so
basic result and in here's what it says
so so suppose you have n numbers theta 1
through through theta n right and what
you want to do is you want to draw an
integer from this set 1 through n at
random and you want the probability that
you pick integer I to be proportional to
e to the power minus theta I okay and
there are many many situations where you
want to do that maybe this theta I is
some kind of an energy from a graphical
model and you know you want to have a
probability distribution whose
probability is proportional to e to the
power minus this energy term right so
these types of Gibbs like distributions
are eyes all over the place so it's not
too crazy for me to ask that I want to
draw from this distribution and in
practical scenarios n is very very large
but but if here think of n as some fixed
small number just to understand the
result okay so so far the Gumbel
distribution is not here but let's bring
it in so the Gumbel distribution is is
is a distribution with this density and
it is mean stable what does mean stable
me it means that if you draw independent
draws from this distribution and you
take the minimum that isn't that is
still a Gumbel
so it's stable under taking minimums and
there is a version of this which is max
stable so so Gamble's come in two forms
means stable and max stable so this is
the mean stable version and what's the
connection of this distribution to to
our original problem it's very
interesting so so it is this perturb and
optimize it perturb and optimize
pipeline that kind of connects to two
things so suppose I take my original
data eyes so remember I have these n
numbers and I want to generate
distribution such that the probability
is proportional to this what I can do is
I can add independent numbers to each
component and then solve and then just
take the minimum after adding the
perturbation
and then the probability is just the
correct one so the probability that you
will select a particular integer 0 from
the set after adding this random
perturbation and minimizing is exactly
what you want okay so that's I mean it's
actually it's surprising that that this
is true so is there something more
general lurking underneath so so this
result actually is kind of known in
social choice theory it's known in
economics people who do graphical model
inference use versions of these to
approximate Bayesian inference and then
it also shows up in online learning as I
discuss more later so how many of you
have seen this result or similar result
before couple of hands this is on the on
the on the positive really any constant
shift will not alter the result because
the admin is insensitive to shiftings
and then there is a corresponding
version for Formax so if you draw from
not the mean stable Gumbel it's max case
stable cousin then you can also get the
arc max version of the the theorem so
far things are making sense stopping
anytime if I stop making sense
okay so online learning so this is a
workshop on real-time decision making
we've seen already online learning come
up in several talks and it will also
show up in later talks Vijay in his very
nice talk on Monday was talking about
online algorithms for matching so within
computer science there are two
communities who look at online
algorithms there are people in machine
learning like me who look at online
learning algorithms and we usually look
at regret and the state of the algorithm
is usually something simple it's maybe a
weight vector that we're learning and
then there are algorithms researcher who
look at online algorithms for solving
combinatorial optimization problems may
be online matching online shortest paths
and and there the the algorithm usually
has a richer State internal state and
and people look at comparative ratio so
there are differences but the two two
communities have have a lot of things in
common so I'm approaching online
learning from more from a machine
learning point of view and these online
learning algorithms as the name suggests
they work in this scenario where you
have data coming at the algorithm in a
sequential incremental fashion and you
want to do some efficient computation
each time more new data arrives and
that's kind of by almost by definition
of the of the set of well-suited to real
time incremental streaming applications
so let's try and talk like I'll spend
the majority of my talk time talking
about perturbations in online learning
okay so so far I was just talking about
perturbations in general but now I want
to talk about motivations are in online
learning so let me just introduce to you
this extremely basic problem in online
learning so people who are experts will
find this extremely boring but this is
just for so that everyone is on the same
page so so suppose you have this is the
famous experts problem so time goes on
in this
which steps 130 at every time step the
learner has to select you know maybe
there are n experts each giving the
learner some advice about how to behave
and at every time the learners job is to
to pick one of the experts one of the
sources of advice
now these experts could be real experts
here maybe humans or computational
models maybe weather models maybe this
is a weather prediction task or they
might just be statistical models right
so this problem doesn't care about the
nature of the entities generating the
these predictions it's pretty abstract
so I choose an integer from I'm the
learner I choose an integer from 1 to N
and then then nature reveals some
outcome which which sets end losses so
every expert at every round suffers some
loss and we assume that that loss is
bounded and we've scaled it so that it's
in the interval 0 to 1 so at after
choosing one of the experts I get to
know the losses of all of the N experts
ok so if I went with an expert that had
high loss well that's a bad day for me
because I should have gone with someone
else who had a smaller loss so I suffer
the loss so LT is a vector every time T
I see a vector after I make my move I'm
the learner I see a vector with n
numbers in it and I suffer one of those
numbers namely the numbers corresponding
to the index that I pick and this
happens again and again and it's typical
this is not the only measure of success
in this setting but this is a very
widely used measure of how good the
algorithm is doing so we will add up our
losses
so LTI T remember that number is what I
suffer instantaneously at any given time
and then I subtract from that the
minimum loss in hindsight so suppose
this game is over after T rounds I can
compute the cumulative loss for each
expert for each fixed I let's say I is 1
I can just add up the losses of the
first expert that's going to be some
number then I can add up the losses of
the second expert and I do it n times
and I say which is minimum so if I knew
the losses in advance I could have just
stuck to one of those experts and
obtain this loss maybe I did worse I'll
just measure this difference and I'll
take the maximum overall ends
maximum of this different overall ends
which because of this - becomes a
minimum here and I call this my degree
this is the learners regret how bad they
feel when they look back so is the
protocol and this definition here how
many of you have already seen regret you
find like this
that's almost everyone so good that's
really good
so some little bit of history so I am I
teach at Michigan and there's Michigan
State University about one hour north
from Ann Arbor and Jim Hannon who is a
statistician in the stats department he
proved one of the earliest results in
this area of online learning using
regret as a as a measure of success and
so now if we if someone designs an
algorithm whose whose regret grows sub
linearly
now why sub linear important because C
losses here are scale right so this
quantity anyways trivially doesn't grow
any any faster than linear in P right at
max I can suffer constant regret so so
if you design an algorithm that has
regret some constant times T that's not
a very good algorithm so I want I want
this regret ideally well maybe this can
be constant that would be great
but at least it should not grow as fast
as T so so because of Hannon's seminal
contributions now we say an algorithm is
Hanan consistent if it's regretted is
small of T and then there are version I
mean you have to be you have to have
regret in high probability if your
algorithm is randomized
and the reason I this is a screenshot of
his his paper called approximation to
Bayes risk in repeated play pop this
back in the 1950s the reason I put the
screenshot here is I don't think you can
read it but the underlined part of this
paper says that what he's doing is is
that he's adding randomness okay so this
idea of you look at the losses the
losses that have occurred in the past
well that's all you got if you learn you
don't know what's coming in the future
all you have are losses from the past
what he said is look at the losses in
the past don't follow the person who
looks best currently because who knows
maybe in the future their bad would add
some random perturbations and then
choose choose the best after perturbing
the losses so that's the part I've
underlined just to show that this idea
was back even in his in the first paper
this idea was it was right there so let
me let me say more so so you it might be
tempting to to design algorithms that
simply minimize the past losses right so
I'm at time T I know for every expert I
know their losses in the past so I'll
just add them up and pick the one that
has the minimum loss that seems like a
reasonable at least a reasonable
starting point and this is called
fictitious play and in the game theory
world and score follow-the-leader and
machine learning it works well but only
under very very sort of very you have to
put a lot of assumptions in general
doesn't work it doesn't even work for
this to experts case so so you here are
two experts here are the losses of
course the learner doesn't know that
these losses are coming on day one we
don't know what they do maybe they just
randomized but after day one having seen
this column and if that's your strategy
you're going to pick the second expert
at day two right because you're going to
say well he this expert got lost half
this expert hasn't suffered any loss so
I should go with expert the second
expert so you go with them and then the
reality flips nature says well this is
bad this is good and now you follow this
one because the cumulative loss after
two days is 0.5 here
and one here and then nature flips again
in a nature away again you know it keeps
doing this alternation and you suffer
Yussef are really really bad regret why
do you suffer bad regret because the
best expert in hindsight is only
suffering constant loss every other
writer suffering loss one every other
round so the loss of the best expert is
growing as T over two but you are
suffering a loss every round so your
loss is T and the difference of T and T
over two is T over two so your regret is
increasing linearly so it's it's an
unstable algorithm it's a deterministic
algorithm so so in an adversarial nature
here is being adversarial and it's able
to take advantage of this instability
that it's very predictable your
deterministic Swee were predictable so
it so it can generate these types of
losses and cause high regret
so Hanna's idea was to stabilize this
algorithm it's very unstable by its
nature
so let's stabilize it and let's
stabilize it in a very peculiar way
let's stabilize it by adding randomness
and this family of algorithms where
instead of following the leader you add
randomness and it's called follow the
perturb leader machine learning and in
in the games here in literature it's
called stochastic fictitious play but I
mean both names convey the same
underlying idea that it's basically
doing the the obvious thing the knife
thing which is well just go by past
performance but just smooth it out a
little bit and a tahir is a trade-off
parameter if eita is too small then
you're adding a lot of randomness and
you're not paying attention to the past
performance which seems weird you should
pay attention to the past performance
and if ETA is the other extreme is when
eta is very very large then you're back
in this deterministic world where you're
just going completely according to past
performance enhance original choice was
he was choosing the Z is independent
across all and experts from the uniform
distribution over z1 so in Hannah's
original 19:56 algorithm these were just
uniform random variables what's
interesting is that you know this is
maybe the maybe if uniform is like maybe
the first continuous distribution that
comes to your mind yeah so that's a good
question do you choose them once or do
you choose them again and again it
depends on what is your assumption on
the adversity of the adversary's
oblivious just chooses the lost sequence
ahead of the game then you can just
choose them once but if the adversity is
adaptive you have to protect yourself
against them realizing what kind of
underlying randomness you're using and
exploiting that then you have to draw
fresh randomness
any other questions about this yeah so
typically so this eita ends up being at
the scale of square root of t yeah yeah
Oh like what information about the game
is needed so actually very minimal so
once you assume that you have bounded
losses and you know the bound that's
pretty much everything you you the way
I've written it it seems like you need
to know how long the game will last but
you can also have a time dependent Etta
so not Etta but it s of T and it usually
doesn't matter whether you use at least
in the simple problem it doesn't matter
whether you know the time horizon
upfront or you slowly decay it as a
function of T so it's not a lot of
information and I will talk about if I
have time I will talk about an algorithm
that is parameter free so this one has a
parameter and in practice you don't want
I'll go through this with the tuning
parameters those who sets them right but
there are versions that are tuning
parameter free any other questions
okay great okay so so so there is a
there is a choice for ETA which actually
gives the correct scaling in this
personal problem it gives you a scaling
of square root T for the regret which is
optimal no algorithm can do better than
that however choosing this simple
distribution which is just uniform does
not give you the right dependence on the
number of experts so you get the right
dependence on the time but you don't get
the right dependence on the number of
experts this is the person this CI over
every type that's outside of the Sun or
it sorry so this is oh yeah my son might
my scope is not clear right so this is
this is just the sum of the losses and
then I'm adding just one one random
number yes there's some lines here
now there are words there are follow the
perturb for follow the perturb leader
algorithms where you move the Zi inside
and then it is a Z is comma I so there's
actually a very nice paper called
prediction using random walk
perturbations where here actually that's
one of the ways to get rid of this
tuning parameter because you add a
random walk and the random walk
inherently scales as square root e so so
actually there is an algorithm where you
add inside the sum but this is Hannan's
original algorithm he didn't do it okay
so okay so so this this this algorithm
this is this is an algorithm family
because we can choose different z is one
particular member of that family already
discovered in the 50s gives the right
scaling in T so that's great but it
doesn't give the right scaling in the
number of experts it gives polynomial
dependence on n while in fact the
minimax optimal is is logarithmic so so
how do we get the right dependence and
we get it through this very very famous
algorithm which again I think almost all
of you have probably heard about it
under different names multiplicative
weights or exponential weights the basic
idea is extremely simple you you
initialize some weights maybe you set
them to one one weight for every expert
and you initially you don't know how
good they are so you just set them to
one and every round what you do is you
use these weights to draw is to say
you'll select one of the experts at
random using those weights you'll select
them with probability proportional to
the weight so you want to keep these
rates non-negative because you interpret
them as unknown wise probabilities and
this is your this is how you will update
your weights so if if an expert doesn't
do very well you you incur a lot of loss
then you downgrade them
so you say the weight goes down e to the
power minus some tuning parameter ETA
times their loss and if they don't get
any loss if loss is zero then you you
you keep the weight as it is right so
this is the famous multiplicative
weights or exponential rates algorithm
and this achieves this algorithm
achieves a optimal regret for this
problem so square root P and then square
root log n that's its dependence on time
and number of experts so this is optimal
now how is this connected
to Hanna's algorithm it just seems like
a different algorithm so the interesting
thing and I gained experts in the in the
field notice so so I'm probably boring
them but if you don't know this it's
very interesting thing to note that
through this Gumble lemma that I showed
you earlier you can reinterpret this
algorithm as a follower perturb
algorithm where your perturbations are
not uniform but they are Gumbel that's a
key thing to remember from this talk
it's the folklore result in machine
learning but it's not widely known
outside of it so recall that FTP all had
this form and it turns out this so this
is the sort of the main point of this
slide and the first part of the talk and
if you remember one thing from the talk
just remember this then exponential
weights is actually it's an FTP
algorithm it's a perturbation based
algorithm but why did you choose your
perturbations from the Gumbel
distribution and this just follows from
the Gumbel lemma so Gumbel Emma said
that if you have some numbers and you
add Gumbel perturbations then the
probability that you will draw the IH
number is proportional to e to the power
minus that number right that's what
Gumbel Emma said so it move this 8 over
to here because the argument doesn't
change under scaling Xandra positive
scalings so this whole thing is I'm
taking the argument of 8 a scaled some
of the past losses plus Zi and if Zi is
the Gumbel distribution then I know that
the probability I will pick a particular
expert is going to be proportional to e
to the minus this thing right so e to
the minus 8 some of past losses that's
going to be the the weighting right and
that's that's what that's what this
algorithm is doing because the weight at
time T is going to be proportional to e
to the power minus 8 are some of the
losses in the past because the you
multiply with then X so these accumulate
additively and inside the expert yes
during the process it's exactly it's
stochastically the distribution you will
be the same yes
so so exponential weights or
multiplicative weights a can be
reinterpreted it's the same algorithm
but you're just reinterpreting it as an
FTP al algorithm but what's interesting
is you you can also view exponential
weights as follow the regularize leader
a loop yes on the previous slide yes the
algorithm is optimal what separator is
because we know if a tie is too small or
too big you're gonna be at a bad
algorithm so it has to be tuned properly
on the previous slide yes when uses a
tie right here oh yeah I should have
added here with the right tuning of ADA
yeah I'm not claiming yeah so this might
seem I'm claiming it's always up to know
with the right or the correctly to Nader
yeah that's the it has to be tuned in
both well it's the same algorithm
actually so it has to be tuned okay so
so I showed you this exponential weights
algorithm and pack number one it can be
interpreted as FTP l with Gumbel
distribution now fact number two and
this is more well-known than the other
one the fact that multiplicative weights
are exponential weights is basically
using entropy as the regularizer
hey what does it mean technically it
means the following that the this the
the probability vector that you put on
the experts using which you draw them
you draw the experts can be obtained as
the solution of this optimization
problem so you this this optimization
variable P it's ranging over all
probability vectors of length n if I did
not have this regularizer
then if I just you know if I just
maximize the minimize the inner product
of a probability vector with a given
vector obviously it is in my best
interest to put all the mass on the on
the least entry right what do I gain by
distributing mass I don't get anything
so if I don't have this which is like a
tie is infinity so then you don't have
this then this is just follow the
leader'
right this part if this part would just
give you follow the reader argument even
though you're doing probabilities it
will actually be deterministic but if
you if you encourage some entropy you
say okay no no I want I want to pay
attention to the past losses but I also
want to have some kind of entropy
entropy inducing behavior in my
optimization problem I can explicitly
add negative entropy as as the term so
entropy is maximized for like completely
uniform distribution which means that
negative entropy is minimized right so
this this this will encourage the
solution to to go towards the uniform
distribution while this will try and
make it deterministic so you then you do
the trade off using ADA as the as the
trading off parameter and this algorithm
with with this choice for my for the
regularizer now this is called the
regularizer in machine learning so we
think of this as the data part this is
what we see from nature and this is what
the designer adds and I'm adding it so
that my algorithm becomes stable and
doesn't over fit too much to what has
happened so that's why I'm calling this
the regularizer and and this family of
algorithms is called follow the
regularize leader just like we have
follow the perturb leader we have follow
the regular wise leader and so if you
use entropy you get exactly exponential
weights
yes so here here here this solution
gives directly gives you the probability
distribution so you sample from it yes I
mean something sampling usually it's
implicit right you just draw from the
posterior but here I am explicitly
giving you here is the vector draw it
from
okay so I have what five five more
minutes what is that okay so maybe I can
go on for another few minutes okay yeah
okay so it's actually this part is
ending so the so far I have not told you
any new work I've already told you
common knowledge in in in the online
learning area but this is this slide
somehow this slide and the following
couple of slides summarize what we
discovered in a series in two papers
written over the past two three years so
so we know this but we know we have this
data point right in our space of
knowledge about algorithms we know that
FTP L with Gumbel is exactly the same as
ft RL with negative entropy that we know
so the obvious question of its
theoretical question is is there
something deeper going on right is this
just an isolated fact or is there some
very generic connection in particular
you can ask things like okay if you if
if I have a particular FTP L algorithm
which is using some perturbations maybe
I don't know Gaussian or normal or
Gumbel can I always find a regularizer
so that I have this equivalence right
and vice-versa if I if you give me a
regularizer then I can or can I always
find a perturbation which is formally
equivalent to it and the answers are a
mix of surprise and not so surprising
maybe so so yes the the connection
between both of these algorithms as is
you they can be understood as different
ways of smoothing a non-smooth function
and this will become clearer clearer in
a couple of slides so that's kind of the
high level answer to the first question
the answer to the second type of
question is yes in this particular in
this experts problem and more generally
in online linear optimization problems
you can always find an equivalent
regularizer so if you start from a
perturbation you can always find a
regularizer and you just use a standard
convex duality eventual duality so
that's a nice direction interestingly it
doesn't work the other way around so
it's not that it's not the case that I
can in fact there are
example so there are regular risers for
which you can prove that there is no
perturbation which will make the perturb
algorithm exactly equivalent to the
regularizer algorithm but I would not
say that the question is fully settled
here because in some sense asking for
exact equivalence is a little bit too
much because okay right maybe the
distribution is a little bit different
as long as the overall learning
guarantee as long as the overall regret
guarantee is still may be within
constant factors it should be okay right
so so so a more general question version
of this question is still open which is
if I give you a regularizer algorithm
for some online learning algorithm and
let's say it's minimax optimal or it has
a particular regret rate can I always
design a perturbation which gives me the
same learning guarantee it maybe doesn't
match the algorithm point-wise in terms
of your distribution but has the overall
same guarantee so that's still open but
at least you can't get it get an exact
equivalent always so sure let me just
let me just spend just one or two
minutes explaining to you what I meant
by you can think of these two as smooth
things of non smooth functions and then
I'll open for questions stop there okay
so so here's here's a non smooth
function so you have a vector you have
this is a function over vector so G is a
vector with n components and this is
just the point wise maximum so what's
the maximum entry in this vector and
this is this is the function that is
beneath the experts problem I have just
converted my means to max so that I get
a convex function otherwise I would have
a concave function and I want to use
convex analysis so this is the basically
this is the unsmooth function this is
the reason why in that counter example
the algorithm is flipping because this
function is non smooth now this maximum
coordinate function can also be written
as the maximum over all probability
distributions simply because the maximum
will be achieved at a pure at a basis
vector
and what what you do is when you when
you add a regularizer and now the sign
is - because you know because of my max
min swap so don't I mean don't get
confused by the sign flip but the point
is this is some this is some non smooth
function of G if I add a nice function
like entropy then it becomes smooth
because after this transformation this
this new function actually has
derivatives is this function does not
have derivatives anytime G has two
entries that are equal then the
derivative is not well defined still has
a sub difference a sub differential
because it's a convex function but it's
not differentiable so this this thing
makes it smooth and this actually this
is a very this is a this is a very
standard type of smoothing in convex
analysis it's called incon smoothing you
take the in female convolution with a
with a strongly strictly convex function
and you smooth the you smooth your
function so this is one type of
smoothing but maybe this is not this
type of smoothing outside if you don't
know my lot of convex analysis you may
not think of this smoothing may be the
more natural smoothing is the the
standard standard integral convolution
smoothing where you integrate your
function against a Gaussian density or
something right it's a normal regular
like Gaussian blur ring for people who
do image analysis and so you could
smooth your you could start from the
same function but you could smooth it
this way right you could say that for
every coordinate I will add some
randomness and then I'll take the
expectation this expectation is under
the randomness in Z so this function
hopefully smooths out the kinks in the
underlying fee because you're involving
with some nice distribution that has a
density
and so this is the integral convolution
smoothing this and the previous one is
in female convolution smoothing so
that's that's nice
so f p RL and ftp L are both smoothing
but they're smoothing in different ways
and the fact that if you have a if you
have a smoothing of this form you will
you can always find a regularizer it's
just duality so this is some smooth
function so you can always look at its
central conjugate and it's it's
conjugate is going to be a strictly
convex function so just almost by for
free from convex analysis there will
always exist a strictly convex function
such that this smoothing can also be
written like this which is what we call
the FT RL type of smoothing so the point
is okay this might not be easy to
compute but will always exist so for
every perturbation there exists a six
strictly convex function such that you
know the FT RL algorithms with that
function is the same as the F DPL
algorithm now I I cheated a little bit
because playing the so playing the
gradients of this function is the same
as running for the follow-the-leader
because you just go after the person
who's who has the maximum gain in the
gain setting or minimum loss in the law
setting in this case playing the
gradient would mean playing the gradient
of this expectation so the gradient is
outside the expectation but that's not
what FTP L does FTP L adds randomness
and immediately optimizes which means
that that gradient operation is
occurring inside the expectation but in
linear optimization problems you know
expectation commutes with linear
functions in expectation it's all okay
but for nonlinear problems that is a
there's an extra step you can't just
talk about these mu things and
immediately talk about regret because
for non linear functions you won't have
the linearity of expectation the
expectation commuting with with linear
functions so actually that's that's it I
had other stuff but it's more technical
and I think I've made the high level
point and I'm also running out of time
so I'll just stop by saying thank you
and if you're interested here are the
papers on which this talk is based and
this is mostly the part I cover so for
the last point that you just made so is
it really that the smoothing isn't
applied to online to lab reject is that
what's going on smoothing is the random
perturbation is actually equivalent to
online dual averaging that's the point
about the non-linearity that you made at
the end no the point about non-linearity
I was making was was so that I'll have
to say two things so so one is that yes
so in optimization also people
understand this so usually you want to
smooth by adding an explicit function
right Nestor of smoothing like you
actually you hunt for a nice function to
add so that after adding and doing the
min and Max I get a nice smooth function
but you can also put up so there's a
very nice paper on semi definite
optimization where this like if you're
max if you are optimizing like the
largest eigen value of a matrix valued
parameter then instead of smoothing it
explicitly maybe you can just add a
little bit of randomness and have a
randomized objective run an algorithm
there and then give bounds on the
original problem by saying that I added
only a controlled amount of items the
point about linearity I was making is
was more of a technical rather than a
conceptual point simply I was yeah and
maybe I didn't have time so maybe I
confused everyone the point I was making
was that the algorithm I described
originally as FTP L is not the algorithm
that plays the gradients of this
function it actually plays the gradient
of the function inside and so there is
this issue of is the differentiation
happening before the expectation is
taking or after and I was simply saying
that if your objective is linear it
doesn't matter in expectation doesn't
matter so that was more of our just a
technical point not a not a high level
conceptual point oh and I should maybe
say one last thing is why why should one
one anyone care about perturbations in
especially if perturbations always have
a regularizer
it's because of efficiency so I that I
didn't say that but FTL algorithms
we're discovered for this reason is that
in a lot of online problems like online
shortest paths it's very easy to solve
it to run FTP l because the article you
need is simply the shortest path Oracle
you're just adding random numbers to the
edges and then feeding it to your
standard algorithm but if you add and
regularizer than the nature of your
optimization problem changes and you
have to feed it to a different solver
[Applause]